pour l'instant pour cela pour que cette
réforme de retraite soit soumise à un
référendum il faut que le Sénat adopte
la motion qui sera discuter ainsi que
l'Assemblée nationale ensuite elle devra
et bien adopter ce texte dans les mêmes
termes ça sera ensuite et bien à
Emmanuel Macron en vertu de l'article 11
de la Constitution et bien de décider si
oui ou non cette réforme doit être
soumise à l'approbation des Français
alors très concrètement très
pratiquement comment ça va se passer
donc quelques instants le et bien la
séance va être ouverte le président du
groupe socialiste Patrick va prendre la
parole il va présenter la motion ce
serait ensuite aux orateurs des autres
groupes d'afficher leur position passer
ensuite à un vote final sur la motion
référendaire entre vous et nous
Alexandre très peu de chances que cette
motion soit adoptée aujourd'hui ça
devrait durer entre 1h30 et 2 heures
vous l'avez vous avez entendu Gérard
Larcher la séance vient d'être ouverte
on va donc suivre l'examen de cette
motion à référ endaire
je n'en vois point ne procès verbal est
donc adopté sous les réserves d'usage
notre ordre du jour rappelle l'examen de
la motion présentée par
les présidents Patrick Kanner la
présidente
et plusieurs de leurs collègues
pendant à proposer au président de la
République de soumettre au référendum le
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif
de la sécurité sociale pour 2023 je vais
immédiatement donner la parole au
président Kanner auteur de la motion
monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
allez-y monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre madame
et monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues au nom de ma collègue Eliane
assassy présidente et de son groupe CRCE
et oui au nom du Président Guillaume
Gontard et de son groupe geste et des
élus de mon groupe sers j'ai l'honneur
de vous présenter cette motion tendant à
proposer au président de la République
de soumettre au référendum ce projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale rectificative pour 2023
toute la bataille menée depuis le 19e
siècle se trouve ainsi résumé la
bataille pour le temps de vivre la
conquête du temps de vie quelle était
cette vie pour un prolétaire au 19e
siècle il n'y avait pas de retraite à la
fin de la vie il n'y avait pas de
journée de repos il n'y avait pas de
weekend
42 ans plus tard mes chers collègues ces
mots du président François Mitterrand
pendant sa campagne présidentielle de 81
résonne avec force dans notre hémicycle
il résonne aussi dans mon histoire
personnelle moi en fond du Nord ce
département où les gens ont deux ans
d'espérance de vie de moins que la
moyenne nationale je sais ce que voulait
dire le mot travail dans le bassinier à
Denain ou Douai dans les usines textiles
de l'île Roubaix au Tourcoing ou dans
l'industrie métallurgique à Maubeuge ou
Dunkerque
le combat de ma famille politique depuis
le premier jour a été de conquérir un
peu de temps de vivre il a fallu
toujours par tout temps sous tous les
régimes politiques arrachés aux
puissants les concessions qu'il
refusaient aujourd'hui se tiennent face
à moi ceux qui veulent revenir sur ces
conquêtes sociales toujours pour les
mêmes raisons l'argent la rentabilité
quoi qu'il en coûte sur le plan social
ce sont le président de la République
la première ministre est son
gouvernement monsieur le ministre les
majorités de droite qu'elles soient
relatives à l'Assemblée nationale ou
indiscutable au Sénat ces forces ne sont
pas simplement face à nous par le
menteur de gauche cela n'aurait pas
beaucoup d'importance elles sont face
aux Français en opposition frontale
aujourd'hui nous nous battons pas pour
leur arracher de nouvelles concessions
nous aurions préféré finalement nous
nous battons pour qu'il n'arrachent pas
du temps de vivre français que pour des
économies budgétaires ils ne mettent pas
en place un nouvel impôt sur la vie
d'autres politiques bien plus solidaires
sont possibles ils ont malheureusement
choisi l'injustice plutôt que l'équité
la retraite par répartition mes chers
collègues est un des piliers de notre
système de protection sociale ce sont
les luttes sociales successives qui
l'ont forgé les périodes historiques qui
l'ont renforcé on peut citer ici la
libération et ces jours heureux et 81 et
ses grandes conquêtes sociales avec ce
texte vous ne vous attaquez pas
seulement aux Français et vous vous
attaquez aussi un pan de notre histoire
certes il n'y a rien étonnant à ce que
la droite tente de détricoter notre
modèle social c'est même son fonds de
commerce le gouvernement comme la
majorité sanatoriale sont dans leur rôle
le faire ainsi en revanche est inédit
choisir une procédure parlementaire qui
fait obstacle à la tenue d'un débat
parlementaire serein éclairé et sincère
pour une réforme d'une telle importance
sans parler des risques
d'inconstitutionnalité cette inédit
fragilisez notre pays avec un texte qui
semble avoir été griffonné sur un bout
de table tant ces auteurs dans maîtrise
pas des contours exacts c'est inédit
faire émerger un front syndical uni tant
la concentration ratée sinon existante
c'est inédit réussir à coaliser une
écrasante majorité de Français même
parmi vos électeurs du premier tour
cette inédit je pourrais continuer comme
cela longtemps revenons sur quelques
points que je viens d'évoquer avant d'en
détailler d'autres vous avez choisi le
détourner l'objectif de l'article 47,1
de la Constitution pour contourner le
Parlement j'ai parlé hier de piraterie
parlementaire je persiste et signe ces
lois de financement au sein de notre
Constitution ne sont pas faites pour
vous mettre en place une réforme de
grande ampleur de notre système de
retraite en dévoyant cette procédure
vous aboutissez un examen trop rapide et
un complet d'une réforme sociale
importante qui relève de la loi
ordinaire une réforme qui aurait dû
d'ailleurs et ça a été dit hier précédé
d'une grande réflexion sur la place du
travail dans notre société la place des
seniors l'égalité femme homme en terme
de salaire par exemple avec cette
procédure ce texte pourrait
potentiellement être promulgué sans
aucun vote d'une des deux chambres c'est
un scandale c'est un bras de fer que
vous engagez avec les Français le
représentant mais vous ne trompez
personne vous faites cela Monsieur le
Ministre car vous n'avez pas de majorité
parlementaire propre pour faire voter
votre réforme
par ailleurs en utilisant cette
procédure vous prenez le risque que le
Conseil constitutionnel censure les
cavaliers sociaux comme vous a
d'ailleurs prévenu le Conseil d'État si
ce projet de loi est voté il pourrait
vous être reproché que ces dispositifs
n'ont pas un effet suffisamment direct
sur les recettes ou les dépenses de la
sécurité sociale quand on enlève assez
sucrettes il ne restera plus que la
pilule à mer
outre les risques d'inconstitutionnalité
que je viens d'évoquer le choix de ces
modalités de débat abîment notre
démocratie que l'on soit clair on
empêchant le temps nécessaire à un débat
de qualité le gouvernement est le
premier comptable de la dégradation du
climat autour de ce débat parlementaire
l'obstruction c'est d'abord vous les
débats tronqués c'est d'abord vous le
passage en force est d'abord vous
ensuite avec ce texte on ne sait pas si
vous êtes coupable du prix ou
d'incompétence tant vous avez varié dans
vos explications cela fait plusieurs
semaines que vous naviguez de contre
vérité en approximation que ce soit sur
la retraite La retraite des femmes sur
les 1200 euros de pension minimale vous
semblez mal connaître votre texte et
vous découvrez ces effets négatifs au
fur et à mesure de son examen surtout
quand nos collègues députés vont aller
chercher les informations à la source et
voyez à quoi je peux faire allusion
s'ensuit une litanie de mensonges pour
camoufler vos insuffisances et votre
politique antisociale je ne m'attarde
pas sur ces points ils seront largement
débattus ces prochains jours mais
s'attaquer avec autant de légèreté à la
retraite par répartition est
inacceptable nous sommes face à un
mécano bancal élaboré par des bricoleurs
je les dis vous n'avez pas de majorité
propre au Parlement pour faire cette
réforme la seule majorité que vous avez
elle est contre vous contre cette
réforme ce sont les Français le front
syndical uni et il faut le souligner a
permis de faire émerger une mobilisation
inédite Pacifique la plus forte depuis
30 ans le 7 mars prochain le monde du
travail réaffirmera haut et fort dans la
rue son opposition au report de l'âge
légal de départ nous sommes aussi leur
porte-voix et pour dire non à la
retraite à 64 ans
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
écoutez les Français ils ont un discours
clair et net de refus de votre réforme
injuste entendez-vous aussi les paroles
des salariés qui disent cette réforme on
ne peut pas on ne tiendra pas jusque-là
s'il se pose à ce point à votre projet
c'est qu'il perd sa jour vous intentions
profondes ils savent que vous êtes en
train de faire des économies sur le dos
des ouvriers les employés qu'ils soient
issus de la classe populaire comme de la
classe moyenne cette obsession du moins
d'impôt obsession du moins d'impôts de
plus en plus dénoncé par les autorités
de régulation financière vous voulez
finalement la faire supporter à six
Français actifs sur 10 soit 18 millions
de nos concitoyens sans aucun effort
demandé à cet extrait minorité de
contribuables qui a tant bénéficié de
l'hyperbouclier fiscale du président de
la République depuis 2017
cela peuvent dormir en paix mes chers
collègues Emmanuel Macron veille à leur
intérêt
les Français ont bien compris que le
ruissellement c'était pour les autres
le président de la République a été élu
pour faire barrage à l'extrême droite
les Français ne lui ont pas donné le de
majorité pour une telle régression
sociale c'est pour cette raison que vous
ne pourrez pas faire passer cette
réforme uniquement et autrement que en
brutalisant la République avec cette
réforme pour résumer vous jouez avec le
feu tant sur la forme que sur la sur le
fond et vous savez qui risque d'en
profiter sur le plan politique nous
appelons retrait de cette réforme mes
chers collègues c'est clair et net mais
faute de retrait nous vous offrons une
autre voie nos trois groupes de gauche
vous offrent une autre voie avec cette
motion référendaire je demande au
gouvernement de montrer son visage et
d'assumer franchement sa politique face
aux Français présenter leur le texte ils
sont dans la rue ils préféreraient aller
sûrement aux urnes mon appel s'adresse
aussi à la majorité sanatoriale qui a
les moyens de voter cette motion faites
honneur à votre famille politique au
gaullisme vous qui chaque année répétez
que la réforme de notre système de
retraite est indispensable pour que les
Français continuent à avoir une retraite
faites trancher cette question
fondamentale par un référendum comme le
permet la constitution imaginée par le
général de Gaulle
mais dernier mot monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
mes derniers mots seront pour le
président de la République lui-même
ce président de la République qui a osé
appeler il y a quelques jours au bon
sens des Français pour défendre sa
réforme le bon sens est de retirer cette
réforme à défaut à défaut
à défaut d'avoir le courage de la
présenter devant les Français mes chers
collègues au nom de nos trois groupes et
pour toutes ces raisons j'encourage la
Haute Assemblée à voter cette motion
référendaire merci monsieur le président
[Applaudissements]
du groupe socialiste au Sénat qui a
défendu la motion référendaire et bien
déposée par les sénateurs de gauche
place maintenant Elizabeth Doisneau à la
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le vice-président de
la commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur de la branche
vieillesse mes chers collègues monsieur
le Président Kanner vous venez de
présenter au nom de votre groupe et
celui de la présidente Eliana Cessy et
du président Guillaume Gontard cette
motion référendaire
nous nous y attendions ce n'est pas une
surprise vous dire si c'est une
un outil on va pas appeler ça une arme
de destruction majeure sans doute pas
sans doute pas chacun
use des outils qu'il a dans sa boîte à
outils
[Rires]
je voudrais je voudrais vous faire part
de deux de deux éléments d'abord une
incompréhension et d'autre part une
conviction pourquoi une incompréhension
parce que monsieur le Président kaner je
sais combien vous êtes attachés à la
démocratie parlementaire vous avez
tellement d'occasions de le montrer vous
avez tellement d'occasions de le prouver
et là aujourd'hui vous nous proposez
finalement un court-circuit on ne
débattrait pas au Parlement on
laisserait la rue choisir pour pour les
Français
alors je vois que ça vous fait réagir
c'est bien c'est bien ça fait réagir ça
fait réagir mais moi je voudrais vous
rappeler monsieur canner les paroles de
François Hollande qui était de gauche il
me semble et qui disait il faut
respecter la démocratie représentative
pourquoi élire des députés pourquoi
élire des sénateurs si toutes les
questions peuvent être posées au peuple
français et cette François Hollande
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors revenons à notre sujet si on
posait la question aux Français
voulez-vous de cette loi vous savez bien
que c'est une question binaire oui ou
non répondre à une telle question
évidemment demander des efforts aux
Français ils vont répondre non et
d'ailleurs les sondages le montrent mais
si on leur dit voulez-vous sauver votre
système de réforme par répartition il
vous diront oui est-ce que vous voulez
laisser la date de vos comment retraite
et celles et vos propres
pensions
est-ce que vous voulez leur laisser ils
diront non
donc je pense qu'il faut être attentif
il faut être attentif aux questions que
l'on pose lors d'un référendum et en
tout cas je ne pense pas qu'ici ce soit
une solution à adopter ma conviction
c'est que nous avons aujourd'hui un mur
de dette et ça c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est encore un socialiste c'est bien
Moscovici le président du Haut Conseil
des finances publiques nous dit que nous
avons un mur de dette et que nous avons
une montagne d'investissement une
montagne d'investissement pour les
armées pour le climat pour restaurer le
service public bref nous avons des
investissements à faire 155 milliards de
dettes encore à amortir sur la cadèse
vous imaginez un petit peu la somme que
ça fait et donc moi je vais pas laisser
cette décision cette décision qui est
lourde j'en prends la responsabilité je
ne veux pas donner voilà au peuple
français c'est responsabilité parce que
j'estime que nous avons à la prendre ici
au Parlement
je voudrais je voudrais aussi terminer
et je veux pas parapher phrasé le
président Chirac qui disait la maison
brûle et nous regardons ailleurs mais là
en tout cas nous oublions la dette et
nous regardons ailleurs je vous propose
de rejeter cette motion de référendaire
merci Madame la rapporteur général la
rapporteur général de la commission des
affaires sociales Elisabeth d'oiseau est
donc opposé à cette idée d'un référendum
sur la réforme des retraites on va
maintenant écouter un autre opposant à
cette motion référendaire René Paul
Savary sénateurs les républicains et
rapporteur de la branche vieillesse de
la sécurité sociale
oui effectivement on peut se poser la
question au référendaire c'est tout à
fait légitime cela voudrait dire que
l'on propose au peuple le texte sur
lequel nous sommes amenés à délibérer la
démocratie est ainsi faite donc nous
refusons le débat nous proposons au
peuple le texte de loi tel qu'il est
ainsi formulé en conséquence ce n'est
pas prendre en compte toutes les
avancées de justice sociale que nous
proposons c'est pas prendre en compte
l'effort supplémentaires
des mères de famille que nous
récompensant à travers une mesure tout à
fait significative avec une pension
meilleure ce n'est pas prendre en compte
suffisamment l'usure professionnelle qui
sera améliorée par rapport au texte dans
ce que nous proposons c'est ne pas
prendre en compte les avancées de
justice en ce qui concerne une
amélioration du dispositif de retraite
progressive et en conséquence c'est une
question brute de décoffrage que vous
refusez aujourd'hui de débattre
deuxièmement nous connaissons l'esprit
des Français toujours un peu
franchouillard gaulois et qui ne
répondent pas qui ne répondent pas
forcément directement à la question et
le référendum est si sensible à la façon
de poser la question
si vous leur aviez posé la question
quand vous avez fait la réforme Touraine
pourquoi vous n'avez pas fait vous
l'aurez rien demandé quoi que l'on
travaille de 41 ans et demi à 43 ans
parce que c'est ça la réalité vous leur
auriez demandé quoi aux Français aux
jeunes de saison vous savez ceux qu'on
catap 5 trimestres avant la fin de leur
année la votre loi assez jeune de 16 ans
vous leur auriez proposé êtes-vous
d'accord de travailler 45 ans
dans la loi là
on leur propose de travailler moins
voilà la façon de poser la question et
si demain vous leur dites ici demain
vous leur dites on a des difficultés
mais voyez on veut pas fait d'efforts
est-ce que vous voulez travailler de 62
à passer de 62 à 64 ans ce serait la
façon dont vous poseriez la question moi
je la poserai pas comme ça je dirais
écoutez si nous ne prenons pas nos
responsabilités est-ce que vous voulez
que nos enfants travaillent 65 ans
plutôt que 64 ans et vous verrez que la
réponse sera différente et si vous avez
entendu
si vous avez entendu
différentes manifestations nous les
avons entendues mais nous avons aussi
écouté les syndicats que nous disent les
syndicats que nous dit la CGT que nous
dit la CFDT il faut débattre du texte
il faut débattre du texte j'étais encore
en discussion avec une déléguée CGT de
mon département elle m'a dit monsieur le
sénateur faut débattre du texte nous
suivons les syndicats nous suivons les
syndicats
en conséquence vous l'avez bien compris
je ne laisserai pas planer le suspense
plus longtemps j'ai mis un avis
défavorable
si monsieur le rapporteur
et leur rapporteur ici au Sénat de la
branche vieillesse de la sécurité
sociale René Paul Savary le sénateur de
la République a donc exprimé son
opposition à cette idée d'un référendum
sur la réforme de retraite on va
maintenant écouter et bien le groupe
RDPI du Sénat c'est le groupe de la
majorité présidentielle avec la prise de
parole de Jean-Baptiste Lemoine qui est
ancien ministre d'Emmanuel Macron dans
le premier quinquennat
madame le rapporteur général monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues évidemment
les sénateurs ne peuvent pas se
décharger de leur mission d'examen de
débat de vote d'un tel projet de loi ce
serait purement et simplement
démissionner et alors que le débat
s'engage à peine vous proposez de
l'interrompre en effet c'est l'article
68 de notre règlement en cas d'adoption
de cette motion que se passerait-il elle
suspend les débats elle va l'Assemblée
nationale son sort est connue bref tout
ça pour ça et je rappelle que le Sénat
un rôle tout particulier en ce moment
celui de débattre des 20 articles du
projet de loi parce que ça n'a pas pu
être fait à l'Assemblée nationale ou
seulement deux des 20 articles ont été
examinés d'ailleurs tant Philippe
Martinez que Laurent Berger le
regrettait je cite ce dernier qui dit
qui a parlé d'un spectacle indigne et
honteux et donc ce souhait d'un débat au
fond du texte c'est pas une lubie ni de
la majorité présidentielle ni de la
majorité sénatoriale c'est un devoir
vis-à-vis des partenaires sociaux c'est
un devoir vis-à-vis des Français et
hélas avec cette notion voulait esquiver
le débat preuve aussi en est le dépôt
d'amendement par milliers parce que
votre ligne elle est simple elle est pas
bouger pas fâchée mais les Français vous
disent aussi pas gouverner depuis deux
présidentielles et donc nous nous avons
une conscience aiguë de la nécessité
d'agir également une conviction que le
Parlement peut être utile et donc nous
ne pouvons accepter cette notion
d'ailleurs si je refais un peu le film
des derniers débats
que ne l'avez-vous utilisé écoutez les
Français nous dit le président kaner
mais moi je me souviens avec le
président Milon en 2016 sur la loi
travail qui mettait en place une
véritable révolution que bernissienne
vous savez grâce à la loi travail on
peut travailler 46 heures par semaine
pendant 12 semaines est-ce que vous les
proposer au référendum non de France à
sur trois à l'époque voulait le retrait
de cette loi avez-vous fait un
référendum à nouveau non et puis si on
parle des retraites la loi Touraine en
2014 elle augmentait la durée
d'assurance à 43 ans la présidente
Laurence Cohen à l'époque disait ça va
frapper de plein fouet les femmes vous
en faites aujourd'hui un choix de
société lavez-vous soumis à référendum à
l'époque non alors je reconnais la
constance du groupe CRCE parce que le
groupe CRCE
déposait Sion portait le faire mais du
côté des socialistes on peut pas dire
que il y a cette cohérence et cette
constance et puis pardon mais si on
parle de la retraite à 60 ans en 81
elle a été instituée non pas par
référendum même pas par débat
parlementaires par ordonnance le
Parlement a été mis hors d'état de
débattre à l'époque
et à l'époque à l'époque Robert Lyon
directeur de cabinet du premier ministre
avertissait sur les risques d'une
retraite à 60 ans dans son rapport
vieillir demain je vous y renvoie et
donc on le voit si référendum il y avait
il faudrait également soumettre
au choix des Français vos propositions
je vois le succès qu'il y aurait
êtes-vous prêt à renoncer à 10% de vos
pensions êtes-vous prêt à payer 15
milliards d'euros d'impôts
supplémentaire chaque année et puis le
référendum comment faites-vous pour
recueillir l'assentiment de celles et de
ceux pour qui nous faisons cette
retraite ceux qui ont 5 mois ceux qui
ont 5 ans ceux qui ont 10 ans ceux qui
ont 15 ans qui ne peuvent pas glisser un
bulletin de vote dans un dans une urne
et qui pourtant ont le droit à une
retraite et ils n'ont pas forcément
droit justement à un régime qui aurait
failli par banqueroute alors que faire
et bien écoutez je me remets mort les
propos du testeur à la onziani en
réponse à une motion référendaire en
2010 dans cette émission et que disait
alain Anziani il disait l'autre façon de
consulter le peuple sur les retraites
c'est l'élection présidentielle et bien
ça tombe bien le président de la
République désamant le premier tour il a
posé le sujet il a dit ce qu'il allait
faire le peuple s'est exprimé au premier
tour il a été clair il l'a envoyé au
second et puis écoutez
vous pouvez prendre le sujet par tous
les bouts vos collègues
socialistes ou sociaux-démocrates
ailleurs en Europe ils n'ont pas fait la
politique de l'autruche ils ont réformé
dans le même sens que ce que nous
proposons c'est le Portugal de José
Socrate 66 ans c'est l'Espagne de José
lui sa pathero 66 ans c'est la Grèce
d'alexispraz souvenez-vous ou Syriza
siriza 67 ans alors oui il faut apporter
des réponses pour les retraités
d'aujourd'hui et de demain évite il y a
urgence pour conseiller le système
urgence pour améliorer les droits
urgences pour travailler sur ce projet
de loi le groupe RDPI votera donc compte
cette notion référendaire pour que nous
puissions poursuivre l'examen du texte
faire notre travail de parlementaire au
service des Français et c'est d'ailleurs
tout le sens de cette belle analyse
livrée dans pouvoir que je vous livre
l'article 11 puisque c'est ce celui-là
dont il s'agit doit être utilisé avec
précaution à propos de textes peu
nombreux et simple dans leur rédaction
sinon il serait préférable que la
population des français fut éclairée par
un large débat parlementaire
François Mitterrand avril 1988 alors je
le dis à nos collègues de l'opposition
soyez mitterrandiens soyez à la hauteur
de votre héritage politique ne le
rengnez pas ce n'est pas une défroque un
vêtement usagé éclairé donc les Français
par ce large débat parlementaire et rush
dans cette motion
merci merci
[Applaudissements]
et le groupe des sénateurs de la
majorité présidentielle et donc opposée
à cette motion référendaire et vous le
voyez vous allez entendre tous les
différents groupes politiques ici au
Sénat qui vont donner leur avis sur
cette idée d'un référendum sur la
réforme des retraites et on va
maintenant écouter une sénatrice
socialiste Emilienne pomirol sénatrice
sénatrice de Haute-Garonne les
socialistes qui dans ce débat sont mis
face à leur bilan notamment sous
François Hollande où il n'y avait pas eu
de référendum sur certaines réformes
à la mer et au vieux travailleurs la
protection de la santé la sécurité
matérielle le repos et les loisirs tout
être humain qui a raison son âge son
état physique ou mental la situation
économique se trouve dans l'incapacité
de travailler a le droit d'obtenir de la
collectivité des moyens convenables
d'existence les forces vivent de la
résistance sont donc appliquées le
programme des jours heureux et ainsi la
France a battit la sécurité sociale et
c'est un moment historique il traduit la
solidarité en lui grâce à la création du
système de retraite qui permet à chacun
de bénéficier de droits acquis grâce à
son travail pour profiter de la vie
c'est la solidarité intergénérationnelle
la politique c'est changer la vie
changer la vie ici et maintenant c'était
le thème que nous portions nous les
socialistes en 1981 et c'est ce que
François Mitterrand fait parmi les
grandes avancées sociales il a mis en
place la retraite à 60 ans parce que
nous savions et nous savons toujours
combien de travail peut être pénible et
endommagé la santé des gens il n'y a
qu'à voir 35% des ouvriers aujourd'hui
seulement travaillent au-delà de 60 ans
parce que leur santé ne leur permet pas
d'aller au-delà or ce gouvernement à lui
enlever les critères de pénibilité la
politique du gouvernement actuel c'est
de dégrader la vie notamment celle des
femmes des précaires celles dont la
carrière est longue changer la vie c'est
pour nous pour l'aide-soignante
d'Aurillac la femme de ménage de
Saint-Denis ou encore la coiffeuse de
Morlaàs si la France du travail qui crie
sa colère dans ses cortèges dans tous
les territoires la retraite avait été
pensé comme un nouveau salaire qui
permet d'employer librement à son rythme
dans des relations autres que des
relations marchandes au bénéfice de la
société tout entière la France tire de
ces retraités une richesse que des
tableaux comptables ne peuvent faire
ressortir ils sont ainsi le premier à
être engagés dans notre tissu associatif
il assure des millions d'heures de garde
d'enfants ils sont les élus de nos
communes vous allez donc réduire de deux
ans leur engagement au bénéfice de la
société contrairement au gouvernement
les Français connaissent cette richesse
et demeur attachés au système de la
sécurité sociale et de retraite ces
dernières semaines ils ont par millions
de manifesté leur rejet dans la rue et
ont rejoint le front syndical uni qui
s'est créé contre votre réforme par la
faute du gouvernement et à cause de
votre vision purement comptable nous
agissons ainsi au plus grandes
manifestations depuis 30 ans ensemble
tous pour empêcher votre réforme injuste
brutale et inutile le 7 mars les
syndicats n'auront diront non le 8 mars
les femmes diront non le 9 mars les
étudiants diront non et enfin le 10 mars
les marches pour le climat diront non à
votre forme injuste et libérale vous
prenez le risque par votre dogmatisme de
mettre le pays à l'arrêt alors dans un
esprit de concorde nous vous proposons
une jabattoir le référendum saisissez-la
le référendum a été inscrit dans notre
Constitution pour que les Français
puissent décider par eux-mêmes de la
voix que les politiques doivent prendre
le général de Gaulle a par quatre fois
décidé de s'en remettre à la sagesse
populaire les crises que la France
travaillait traversait alors ont amené
nos concitoyens à prendre leur
responsabilité pour décider de leur
avenir or l'avenir des Français c'est
précisément l'enjeu de cette réforme il
est prioritaire d'intégrer les Français
dans la discussion et ne les associés à
la construction de le futur société
aujourd'hui plus de deux tiers des
Français s'opposent à votre réforme des
millions l’ont créé dans la rue et le
gouvernement ne dispose pas de la
légitimité pour faire cette réforme
contrairement à ce que dit le président
de la République Monsieur Macron il n'a
pas été élu sur son programme mais pour
empêcher l'arrivée au pouvoir de
l'extrême droite et d'ailleurs le
président de la République n'a pas
obtenu de légitimité puisque les
législatives suivantes ne lui ont pas
donné de majorité ce qu'il oblige à
composer avec les élus de droite la
souveraine était nationale appartient au
peuple ainsi lorsque le peuple est en
désaccord avec ses représentants il ne
reste que la voix du référendum
aujourd'hui je sais qu'à ma gauche le
choix de poser la question à nos
concitoyens a été prise je me tourne
alors vers ma droite par une curieuse
coïncidence que seule l'histoire s'est
créée il revient au peuple
au groupe pardon hérité du gaullisme de
trancher la question de proposer ou non
un référendum mes chers collègues il
vous appartiennent d'offrir à nouveau au
peuple les clés de son destin
le groupe socialiste du Sénat donc
défendu l'idée d'un référendum sur la
réforme des retraites on va écouter un
autre groupe de gauche à l'initiative de
cette motion référendaire le groupe
communiste avec la prise de parole de la
sénatrice Laurence Cohen sénatrice
communiste du Val-de-Marne modèle
référendum sur ce projet de recul de
l'âge de départ à la retraite sonne
aujourd'hui comme une évidence monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues de la
majorité présidentielle et sénatoriales
aujourd'hui main dans la main je vous le
redis le rejet de cette mesure
provocatrice est massif dans ce pays
c'est une provocation de répondre par
l'obligation de travailler plus
longtemps à la détresse à l'angoisse de
la population frappée par la crise du
covid victime d'une précarité croissante
dans le travail et dans la vie
quotidienne et qui subit une inflation à
deux chiffres sur les produits
alimentaires et de première nécessité
c'est une provocation à l'égard des
femmes déjà victimes de discrimination
en matière salariale d'évolution de
carrière plutôt que l'égalité vous
ajoutez de la maltraitance en
rallongeant soit leur travail soit leur
période de chômage car vous savez bien
qu'en reculant l'âge de la retraite
c'est le chômage des seniors que vous
prolongez le message que vous envoyez
aux femmes et des plus cyniques vous
leur dites qu'elles vont travailler plus
longtemps mais que l'écart entre leurs
pensions et celles des hommes qui
s'élèvent faut-il leur rappeler à 40 %
va être moindre mais ce que veulent les
femmes ce n'est pas un écart cosmétique
c'est l'égalité
depuis 2017 le président Macron a fait
de l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes une grande cause nationale alors
mettez on adéquation ces paroles et ses
actes l'égalité salariale et l'égalité
d'accès à l'emploi des femmes
permettrait de résoudre le pseudo
déficit qui justifie votre réforme
unique avec les amis de mon groupe mais
aussi de toute la gauche sénatoriale
nous sommes scandalisés par les
propositions de Monsieur Retailleau
s'appuyant sur une idéologie
familialiste nationaliste d'une époque
que je n'oser non monsieur Retailleau
les femmes ne peuvent avoir pour seule
solution afin d'éviter de travailler
jusqu'à un âge indéterminé que de faire
plus d'enfants nous vous demandons de
retirer proposition par dignité c'est
une provocation à l'égard de la jeunesse
durement éprouvée par le covid par un
monde incertain des guerres dans de
nombreux pays la menace d'une troisième
guerre mondiale une jeunesse confrontée
à cette inquiétant réchauffement
climatique soumise à un parcours
scolaire et universitaire de plus en
plus sélectif dans des conditions de
plus en plus difficiles que
proposez-vous à la jeunesse un service
national universel autoritaire une forme
d'embryadement insupportable pour celles
et ceux qui ont soif de liberté et une
carrière qui ne se terminera qu'avec la
vieillesse car quel étudiant pourra
espérer une retraite avant 70 ans c'est
une provocation pour les travailleuses
et les travailleurs y compris celles et
ceux qui exercent des métiers pénibles
ou une carrière longue ou maltraitez
aujourd'hui celles et ceux que vous
couvriez hypocritement de louange ses
premières et premiers de corvées durant
la crise du covid oui la colère est
grande et elle s'amplifie la cotisations
à compter du 7 mars annonce massive
c'est une très bonne nouvelle et hier
dans l'hémicycle nous avons pu vivre
cette opposition entre deux projets de
société aux antipodes dans un clivage
droit de gauche enfin assumé y compris
au bord du gouvernement monsieur Macron
et son gouvernement veut passer au
forceps en utilisant cette procédure de
l'article 47.1 si décrié depuis sa mise
en œuvre pour l'examen de cette réforme
des retraites et qui relèvent du
détournement de procédures nous l'avons
affirmé hier vous violez la Constitution
pour imposer cette réforme vous
contraignez le Parlement vous tentez de
le soumettre et sommes choqué par cette
majorité sénatoriale qui avait affiché
son statut de contre-pouvoir de lieu de
résistance à l'autoritarisme de Monsieur
Macron à se mépris du Parlement et qui
aujourd'hui l'accompagne avec
complaisance et oui mes chers collègues
vous accompagnez le président de la
République dans cette mise au pas du
Parlement pire cet engin man du
Parlement puisqu’un non soumis au vote
de l'Assemblée nationale et peut-être
même non soumis au vote des deux
chambres si le gouvernement n'ouvre pas
plus de jours de débat un débat et une
adoption CMP dominée par des
parlementaires LR pourtant en perte
d'influence dans l'opinion publique
c'est un coup de force institutionnel il
faut donner au peuple les moyens d'y
résister lui donner les moyens c'est lui
donner la parole c'est soumettre ce
texte au référendum qui ici pose et dire
alors que plus de 90% des actifs
rejettent le texte restez entre nous au
Sénat validons ce texte fondamental dans
un temps contra int et barons la route à
l'expression populaire tout vote contre
cette motion référendaire est un acte
grave contre la démocratie celles et
ceux qui sentait trop dans ce déni de
démocratie porteront la responsabilité
de la mise à l'arrêt du pays et d'une
légitime révolte avec le groupe CRCE je
vous appelle donc seul aliment à voter
cette motion référendaire sans éviter
il avait donné maintenant le groupe
communiste qui a donc défendu cette
motion effet Inder que les communistes
soutiennent avec les sénateurs
socialistes et les sénateurs écologistes
on va maintenant écouter le groupe
centriste qui forme la majorité de
droite et du centre ici au Sénat le gros
centriste qui est favorable sur le fond
à cette réforme des retraites
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames monsieur les
rapporteurs chers collègues un premier
mot à nouveau pour saluer les
rapporteurs leur travail à la fois sur
le fond du texte mais aussi du point de
vue de l'analyse et puis sur la méthode
et saluer leur leur calme leur
modération c'est important le calmer la
modération on vient de le voir
leur capacité de d'écoute de dialogue
d'échanges et de pédagogie et même leur
sens de la formule ils viennent d'en
faire la démonstration votre travail
grandit notre institution le Sénat et
donc merci nous sommes rassemblés ce
matin pour discuter d'une motion
référendaire je veux tout de suite au
nom du groupe UC dire mais sans l'ombre
d'une hésitation que nous ne la voterons
pas pour des raisons
d'opportunités mais également pour des
raisons de fonds du point de vue de
l'opportunité nous sommes rassemblés
pour débattre de l'avenir de notre
système de retraite et pour nous il
serait tout à fait inoportun de refuser
ce débat s'exonérer du débat sur les
retraites ici et maintenant en
choisissant le référendum cela
reviendrait pour nous à refuser
l'obstacle et ça c'est pas une méthode
pour nous voilà pour l'opportunité sur
le fond notre groupe j'ajoute appartient
à une tradition politique qui pense que
le référendum doit être réservé à la
matière institutionnelle pour les
questions sociétales comme pour les
questions économiques et sociales nous
pensons que c'est le rôle du Parlement
de débattre et de voter j'ajoute que
cette motion référendaire la beauté
reviendrait à créer un redoutable
précédent parce que ça nous interdirait
pour longtemps de débattre des retraites
ici au Parlement parce que pourquoi on
fera un référendum maintenant et par
ensuite sur des débats comme ça et
pourquoi sur des questions aussi
essentielles que des questions
sociétales économiques et sociales on
demanderait pas systématiquement un
référendum et donc un précédent comme
cela serait tout à fait irresponsable ce
serait d'ailleurs porter un bien mauvais
coup à la démocratie parlementaire donc
pour nous c'est clairement bon à cette
notion référendaire je veux à présent
profiter de temps qu'il me reste pour
discuter du texte sur les retraites mais
aussi du contexte de ce débat vous
l'avez compris hier au travers des
interventions de Hervé Marseille et de
Jean-Marie laurenberg notre groupe c'est
clairement positionné pour cette réforme
ah oui mais alors quand on dit oui mais
quelquefois c'est un petit oui un grand
mais non là c'est une forme d'équilibre
et c'est un oui mais c'est un oui bien
sûr et un mail parce qu'il faut
améliorer ce texte ce sera d'ailleurs
dans une double volonté une un certain
équilibre bien sûr mais la volonté
d'enrichir ce texte notamment sur les
pour les femmes les familles les
carrières longues et l'emploi des
seniors nous saluons et approuvons
d'ailleurs les avancées de la Commission
en termes d'équité en termes de justice
mais nous proposerons aussi par
l'intermédiaire de quelques amendements
d'aller plus loin encore tout en
veillant à l'équilibre financier du
texte c'est fondamental cette question
de l’équilibre financier de cette
réforme parce qu'il faut qu'elle vaille
la peine sinon les Français ne
banqueraient pas de nous dire tout ça
pour ça et ils auraient raison un
système de retraite repose sur la
solidarité entre les générations voilà
pourquoi je ne comprends toujours pas la
timidité du gouvernement en matière de
politique familiale à l'aube de ce débat
sur les retraites le choix du
gouvernement lors du dernier PEL FSS il
faut le rappeler d'avoir privé la
branche famille de 2 milliards d'euros
m'apparaît encore plus aujourd'hui
totalement inappropriée c'est pourquoi
l'un de nos amendements phares sera
celui qui prévoit une mesure d'âge ça va
pas plaire sur certains bancs tout
simple la retraite à 60 ans pour les
familles de deux enfants et 64 ans pour
les familles de trois enfants et plus je
ne crains pas d'assure d'assumer on est
un certain nombre ici dans cette
hémicycle l'urgence d'une politique
familiale et nataliste au moment où la
France ne renouvelle plus les
générations avec un taux de natalité
inférieur à deux ça sonne comme une
évidence bien sûr vous l'avez compris
notre groupe est très attaché
à notre système de financement de
retraite par répartition c'est pourquoi
nous voulons aborder ce débat les yeux
ouverts et en toute lucidité se donner
les moyens de financer la retraite de
plus de 20 millions de retraités et non
seulement à des filles mais une exigence
morale qui imposent d'imposer
d'anticiper les besoins de financement
croissants nous partageons le principe
que seul le travail et je dirais même
l'augmentation de la quantité de travail
produite pendant notre pays peut
garantir le financement de notre
protection sociale et donc le
financement de la branche vieillesse et
des retraites mais au-delà de la
question du financement nous sommes
attachés à la valeur de travail ce n'est
pas sur les bancs du groupe UC que se
fera entendre un éloge de la paresse
c'est pourquoi il nous semble
indispensable d'organiser dans les
meilleurs délais un début de base sur le
travail et la rémunération des salariés
j'ai la conviction que les partenaires
sociaux sont prêts à aborder cette
discussion en responsabilité un tel
débat sur le travail nous permettra
d'aborder dans la sérénité je le répète
cette question essentielle de l'emploi
du Seigneur un index le Seigneur est un
premier geste il est nécessaire mais
sera-t-il suffisant j'ai bien peur que
la réussite de cette réforme passe par
la possibilité de tous et tous de
s'épanouir dans son emploi jusqu'à 64
ans d'ailleurs pour nous le débat sur le
travail est indispensable pour preuve un
sondage publié hier démontre combien les
Françaises et les Français en viennent
parfois à douter de l'importance du
travail au lendemain de la crise covid
ainsi je ne me résous pas à lire que 58%
des Français contre 49 en 2019 voit le
travail comme une contrainte quand 42%
seulement il voit un moyen de se
réaliser ils étaient
51% 2019 avoir un moyen de se réaliser
ce recul est alarmant pour notre pays je
refuse de compter parmi les déclinistes
mais reconnaissons que ce changement
profond s'il venait à durer s'il est
anthropologique est un germe de déclin
de notre pays ce débat sur le travail
dans la société poscovite doit permettre
d'approfondir de nombreux sujets je
comprends je pense au travail de Senior
je le répète à une augmentation des
salaires à la veille du retour de
l'inflation conséquence peu surprenantes
du quoi qu'il en coûte et de l'injection
massive d'argent public dans l'économie
je pense à la pénibilité des métiers je
pense à la question des métiers en
tension je pense enfin à la formation
tout au long de la vie qui doit donner à
celle et à ceux qui en ont la volonté de
pouvoir changer une métier le bien-être
au travail l'épanouissement au travail
voilà le défi auquel nous sommes
collectivement confrontés même si nous
pensons qu'il faut aller plus loin en
termes d'équité de justice nous faisons
le pari qu'il y aura une réforme des
retraites mais au lendemain de
l'adoption de cette réforme il y aura
obligation de recoudre notre tissu
social et ce sera notre dernière
remarque au nom du groupe UC comme la
formule est hier notre Président nous
demandons l'organisation d'une
conférence sociale qui pourra avoir pour
objectif la refondation du paritarisme
pour recréer la confiance dans ce pays
qui est dégradé la rémunération des
salariés et puis la place du travail
dans nos vies mais chers collègue vous
l'avez compris notre groupe a envie de
débattre d'aller au bout de ce débat de
conclure ce débat c'est le rôle et la
mission et la responsabilité du Sénat et
donc pour toutes ces raisons que je
viens dénoncer notre groupe de votre APA
cette motion référendaire je vous
remercie merci
le groupe centriste du Sénat qui est
donc contre cette motion référendaire on
va maintenant écouter le président du
groupe RDSE au Sénat Jean-Claude requier
le groupe RDSE c'est le groupe radical
de la Haute Assemblée
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mal à la président de la
cohésion de l'agence sociale mesdames
Messieurs le rapporteur mais sa collègue
la motion tendance à soumettre
référendum le projet de loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour une 2023 appel de question
faut-il un débat faut-il une réforme
retient des bas pour un groupe la
réponse est oui nous savons combien la
Constitution dont les moyennes faire
passer un texte si le gouvernement est
déterminé à le faire en espèces hier
après-midi par la double voie des
ministres nous avons ambi entendu que
compromis était souhaitable mais aussi
que la réforme était incontournable les
regards sont marqués sur le Sénat
assemblés bien souvent ça faut-il le
démontrer quel que soit le style qui va
être le nôtre espérons qu'ils soient au
moins en moins de respect ce que nous
avons pas vu à l'Assemblée nationale à
choqué beaucoup de nos concitoyens
beaucoup des groupes ça nous
travaillaient à la mort sur ce texte
depuis des semaines pour tenter
d'améliorer cette réforme dit retraite
au sein du RDSE nous allons écouter
syndicats et experts la commission de
l'affaire sociale a pris sa part nous
avons déposé des amendements certains
groupes par centaines que notre
administration a enregistré et
le renforcement du droit du Parlement
est un combat qui est un sénat toujours
mené à l'occasion de chacune des
réformes constitutionnelles nous ne
pouvons pas de ce droit d'examiner un
texte fondamental comme des mêmes il ne
fait pas l'unanimité c'est le principe
de base de la démocratie débattre c'est
ainsi
collègue doit-on prendre le risque de
reculer nécessaire et qui est financier
leur système de retraite car oui le
temps de la réforme est venu les
chiffres ont été rappelés hier par nos
collègues rapporteurs le système sera
déficitaire de cette année à hauteur de
1 milliard 800 millions d'euros le
déficit pourrait atteindre puis de 13
milliards en 2030 la redresse simple
notre régime de retraite et solidaire au
point qui ne supporte pas l'allongement
de l'espérance de vie il a le défaut de
sa qualité la solidarité
intergénérationnelle qui est au cœur de
notre pacte républicain j'ajouterai que
le système paraît partition est au cœur
du pacte social donc oui il faut les
réformes rapidement bien entendu par
n'importe quel prix mon collègue
Cavalaire qui est intermé à la
discussion générale la rappeler regardez
c'est longtemps défendu une réforme
systémique pour une retraite à point ça
rancune face à l'abandon de ce projet un
temps évoqué par le Président de la
République mon groupe ne rejette pas en
bloc votre projet monsieur le ministre
qui au fond le fait qu'accélérer la
réforme Touraine
néanmoins si nous sommes ouverts en
compromis nous avons des attentes les
carrières longues la revarie
revalorisation des droits des femmes la
compensation de l'engagement civique la
pénibilité et l'emploi du Seigneur bien
sûr et disons-le aussi la participation
des entreprises ayant Grangé les
dividendes de conséquences en pleine
pour à l'achat ne doit pas être écarté
il y a parfois de renaissance lorsqu'on
confronte le besoin de financement leur
système de retraite et les chiffres des
montants distribués aux actionnaires une
information
doit reposer sur l'équités et dans ce
sens qu'il nous faut travailler et
entendre toutes les sensibilités ici et
bien sûr écouter aussi nos concitoyens
qui s'inquiètent mais chers collègues
parce que le Seigneur doit se mettre son
rôle le rdhc préfère le débat ainsi la
grande majorité de mon groupe ne votera
pas la motion référendaire
merci monsieur le Président et donc le
groupe RDSE le groupe radical du Sénat
qui souhaite un débat sur le fond de
cette réforme de retraite et qui est
donc opposé à cette motion référendaire
on va maintenant écouter le groupe les
républicains les sénateurs les
républicains qui forment la majorité de
la droite et du centre du Sénat et qui
sont favorables à cette réforme de
retraite ils sont donc opposés à cette
motion référendaire madame la Présidente
de la Commission d'affaires sociales
madame la rapporteur général mesdames et
messieurs monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
déposer une motion référendaire
s'inscrirait dans une stratégie je cite
à combattre sans obstruer
stratégie ou stratagème nous sommes en
droit de nous interroger en effet les
auteurs de la motion crient au scandale
pour la logement de l'âge de la route de
l'ouverture des droits à 64 ans en
disant que l'on pousse les Français à
travailler plus longtemps mais n'est-ce
pas mes chers collègues la réforme
Touraine qui prévoit une durée de
cotisation de 172 trimestres soit 43 ans
pour bénéficier d'une retraite à taux
plein or la moyenne d'âge d'entraide sur
le marché du travail est de 22 ans et si
je compte bien 22 + 43 ça fait 65 alors
vous allez me répondre que les Français
peuvent toujours partir à 60 ans oui
mais avec quelle retraite
n'ayant pas une retraite à taux plein
leur pension subira une décote
c'est une machine en fait à créer des
retraités plus pauvres et nous ne
voulons pas
invoquer le référendum pour donner la
parole au peuple sur un sujet qu'il
concerne directement
témoignerait témoignerait d'une volonté
démocratique affirmée
tel est le synopsis mais qu'en est-il
vraiment monsieur le Président Canada
pourquoi déposer une motion référendaire
dont les chances d'aboutir semblent bien
mince
pourquoi déposer une telle motion qui si
elle devait aller à son terme
reviendrait à dessaisir le Parlement de
son pouvoir de débattre de son pouvoir
d'amender et donc de son pouvoir
d'améliorer un texte particulièrement
important en effet à travers le prisme
de la retraite nous parlons de travail
nous parlons d'égalité homme-femmes nous
parlons de justice sociale nous parlons
de santé sujet qui m'est cher nous
parlons de vieillissement c'est donc un
projet de société qui soustend ce texte
et il serait illusoire et bien naïf de
penser qu'un référendum permettrait de
répondre aux différents enjeux de la
réforme des retraites
au nom d'un retour à une légitimité
populaire exprimée via un instrument de
démocratie directe la proposition de
recourir au référendum revient à
empêcher tout débat au fond
pour être pertinent et exprimer une
réelle volonté populaire le référendum
d'importer sur des questions claires
précises concise et limitée la
complexité des situations liées à la
retraite permettent de répondre à ces
exigences
ne risquent-ils pas de se muer en
plébiscite entraînant une
personnalisation extrême du débat
masquant les enjeux et cristallisant les
tensions d'une société fracturée
vous me permettrez de reprendre les
propos du professeur de microusseau le
microusseau qui lui-même a déjà été cité
hier par notre collègue Eliane assassy
je cite Dominique Rousseau la démocratie
a besoin d'institutions intermédiaires
pour fonctionner sereinement et éviter
une personnalisation excessive du
pouvoir je cite encore le référendum
laisse penser que ces institutions sont
un obstacle à la démocratie
alors qu'elles sont précisément les
instruments qui font passer de la
barbarie à la civilisation fin de
citation c'est pourquoi c'est pourquoi
je m'interroge sur cette volonté de
s'auto mutiler
après des débats affligeants à
l'Assemblée nationale tout le monde l'a
dit qui ont encore davantage assombri
l'image des parlementaires et creuser le
fossé entre élu et citoyen il est
particulièrement important voir vital
pour les démocraties représentatives
d'assumer notre mission d'exprimer
clairement nos positions et de défendre
nos opinions les syndicats ont de ce
point de vue jusqu'à ce jour fait preuve
de responsabilité en jouant leur rôle
les élus politiques
serait-il moins capables que les élus
professionnels de remplir les
obligations de leur mandat je pose la
question je souhaite j'espère et je suis
persuadé que tous ensemble dans cette
hémicycle nous saurons avec
détermination conviction faire évoluer
ce texte monsieur le ministre cette
réforme n'est peut-être pas proposée au
bon moment il aurait fallu que le
gouvernement prenne en compte les
propositions du Sénat beaucoup plus tôt
en effet depuis 2019 depuis 2019 la
commission d'affaires du affaires
sociales du Sénat recommande l'adoption
de la réforme paramétrique des retraites
afin de préserver la soutenabilité
financière du système et donc sa
pérennité pour les générations futures
Serge René Paul nous devons agir pour ne
pas laisser filer les déficit je vous
rappelle plus de 150 milliards d'euros
cumulés pour les 10 prochaines années et
c'est prévisions sont très optimistes
puisque basées sur un taux de chômage à
4,5%
cette réforme est donc urgente proposée
par la majorité sénatoriale depuis
plusieurs années le report de la geigale
et l'allongement la durée de cotisation
vont enfin être mis en oeuvre mais si
nous partageons la philosophie globale
du projet pour garantir la pérennité de
notre système nous avons fait de
nombreuses propositions pour améliorer
la situation des Françaises et des
Français en particulier celle des
seniors celle des mers de famille celles
des enfants félins et celles du handicap
faudra relire le texte vous vous révérez
que c'est vrai si vous dit c'est pas
vrai c'est parce que vous n'avez pas lu
nous souhaitons également promouvoir un
système plus équitable notamment à
travers la lutte contre la fraude et la
participation de tous les salariés à
l'effort de travailler plus
nous aurons l'occasion mes chers
collègues d'y revenir en détail au cours
de l'examen des articles et des
discussions mes chers collègues nous ne
pouvons renoncer à nous prononcer sur ce
texte nous ne pouvons pas nous défausser
c'est pour toutes ces raisons que le
groupe LR ne votera pas cette motion et
que nous consacrerons le temps imparti à
un débat argumenté en nous appuyant sur
le travail considérable réalisé par nos
rapporteurs je vous remercie merci
et les sénateurs de la républicains qui
veulent donc un débat sur le fond dans
cette hémicycle du Sénat sur une réforme
des retraites qu'ils soutiennent ils
sont donc opposés à cette motion
référendaire déposée par la gauche on va
maintenant écouter le groupe les
indépendants au Sénat le groupe Les
Indépendants ce sont des sénateurs de
droite mais qui sont par principe
constructif avec le gouvernement on va
écouter le sénateur Daniel Chassin
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
madame la Présidente de la Commission
mesdames messieurs importants mes chers
collègues le programme du président de
la République
candidat avait dans son programme le
départ à la retraite à 64 ans mais c'est
vrai que beaucoup ont voté pour faire
opposition au RM le Sénat
a aussi depuis plusieurs années voter un
amendement concernant cette mesure nage
au PLFSS pour le départ en retraite
même mes chers collègues si les comptes
de la branche retraite étaient en voie
de l'amélioration il serait je pense
agréable à tous de renoncer à ce projet
qui mobilise c'est vrai les syndicats
que j'ai rencontré dans mon département
et beaucoup de Français hostiles à cette
réforme
nous savons tous que la branche retraite
va se dégrader cela est confirmé encore
avec ça vient d'être dit parallèle Lyon
avec
14 millions par an 2030 26 en 2040
pourquoi bien je répète ce que j'ai
quand même dit hier mais je le répète le
nombre de cotisants pour un retraité
passer de 4 en 1970 à 2 en 2000 1,7 en
2020 en
1970 espérance de vie était 70 ans pour
les hommes et 76 pour les femmes on est
passé à 79 et 86 nous étions à ce moment
à 4 millions de retraités on est à 17
millions et 21 en 2030 les générations
futures risquentent plus pouvoir assumer
le régime de retraite par répartition
mis en place en 1945 si les cotisations
doivent augmenter pour maintenir le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités d'autre
part ça a été dit le dynamisme
démographique qui a été longtemps une
forme de la France décroît l'effet sont
là ils nous devons débattre pour
équilibrer les retraites sans majorer
des cotisations en augmentant le travail
le plus légèrement possible afin de
maintenir les retraites par répartition
et la sécurité social
c'est pour cela que j'avais souhaité une
loi travail avec une concertation avec
les partenaires sociaux avant ce projet
de loi cela afin que les personnes
handicapées Invalides carrière longue
les femmes puissent avoir une retraite
plutôt mais aussi une meilleure prise en
compte des critères pénibilité
tout ça avec les partenaires sociaux
renforcer les trimestres octroyés pour
les enfants renforcer les emplois
seniors cumulent emploi retraite avec de
nouveaux droits pour les aidants pour
l'arrose des petites retraites
intégration de l'apprentissage à ça de
trimestres etc valoriser également les
engagements au niveau associatif et bien
d'autres pour lesquels mes chers
collègues vous avez fait des amendements
sur ce texte
cela bien sûr me semble être de la
compétence des affaires sociales du
Sénat
d'autre part j'avais fait un amendement
j'ai fait un amendement de revoyure en
2027 afin de faire un bilan et pourquoi
pas rajouter en fonction des résultats
et bien un autre moyen de financement et
si amélioration mais pourquoi pas faire
marche arrière mais ça se m'étonnerait
mais pour en revenir au ranch random
quelle question allez vous poser la
question sur le recul de l'âge légal
sûrement mais aussi est-ce que vous
allez poser la question de la
suppression de la loi Touraine mise en
place sur le quinquennat de François
Hollande avec 172 trimestres 43 ans de
cotisations pour une retraite complète
je rappelle que si cette loi Touraine
est conservée en l'état pour 43 ans de
cotisations 2035 et bien pour une
personne née en 1971 qui a débuté son
travail en 1992 à 21 ans il partira avec
une retraite à taux plein 43 ans plus
tard c'est à dire en 2035 mais il aura
64 ans est-ce que François Hollande a
fait ça pour brimer les Français mais
non c'est bien pour équilibrer les
retraites les Français savent bien
qu'une réforme ne peut pas se résumer à
une simple question fermée sur autant de
projets essentiels cités
pour nos concitoyens il est donc
nécessaire d'avoir un véritable débat
démocratique c'est au Sénat que nous
pouvons amender ce texte pour mieux
tenir compte des situations
particulières par ailleurs je rappelle
que aucun des précédents projets de
réforme des retraites n'a déjà passé par
un référendum nous cédons donc débattre
amender ce texte pour une réforme la
plus juste possible le groupe Les
Indépendants rejettera cette notion de
référendum merci
mon cher collègue
et donner la parole au président de la
part du groupe les indépendants au Sénat
il faut débattre dans cette hémicycle de
la réforme des retraites alors je le
rappelle trois groupes de gauche ont
déposé cette motion référendaire les
socialistes les communistes et on va
maintenant écouter le groupe écologiste
du Sénat administrative également de
cette motion avec le président du groupe
Guillaume gantard monsieur le ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les dames les
rapporteurs l'examen d'une motion
référendaire une première dans cette
enceinte depuis une décennie est un
moment d'une extrême gravité
démocratique
nous parlementaires n'avons pas vocation
à nous dessaisir de la mission que nous
ont confié les citoyennes et les
citoyens de délibérer et voter la loi
et si nous sommes favorables à davantage
d'implication citoyennes dans la
fabrique de la loi la binarité du
référendum semble souvent peu
compatibles avec l'exercice complexe de
rédaction et de vote de la loi
alors pourquoi cette motion tout d'abord
parce que ce débat parlementaire est une
farce
le gouvernement a choisi un véhicule
législatif inadapté jamais utilisé pour
une réforme de cet ampleur qui corset le
débat dans le temps et dans l'espace en
interdisant de l'élargir au-delà des
paramètres financiers symboles s'il en
est que pour vous le nettoyage n'est
qu'un coup
au moins en son temps Edouard Philippe
avait eu le courage de proposer un vrai
projet de loi et une vision nous la
contestions évidemment mais elle avait
le mérite de proposer autre chose autre
chose qu'une réforme de comptable en
costume gris destiné à faire payer au
travailleur les cadeaux fiscaux offerts
aux entreprises et au plus aisées le
Sénat doit donc examiner et c'est une
délétère première historique un texte
qui n'a pas été voté par l'Assemblée
nationale qui doit absolument être voté
avant le 12 mars minuit faute de quoi le
carrosse redeviendra citrouille mais et
nous sommes ici en Absurdie la
citrouille peut tout de même faire
l'objet d'un examen en commission mix
paritaire ou d'une adoption par
ordonnance la Cinquième République n'est
jamais en reste pour piétiner le
Parlement mais la présidence Macron a
innové comme aucun autre avant-elle dans
la dérive autocratique d'un exécutif
hors-sol isolé dans sa tour d'ivoire
isolé ou devrais-je dire plutôt dire non
content de mépriser le parmement de
mépriser les partenaires sociaux de
l'éveil contre vous un front social qui
comme rarement sait qui comme rarement
c'est le peuple de France tout entier
que vous méprisez depuis des mois tous
les sondages affichent une opposition
ferme et constante aussi ont entre deux
tiers et les trois quarts de nos
concitoyens plus vous méprisez leur
intelligence et invoquer le besoin de
faire de la pédagogie de votre réforme
plus les Français s'y opposent les
manifestations enregistrent semaine
après semaine des records de
participation et les préavis de grève
tombent les uns après les autres pour
faire du 7 mars et de la prochaine
semaine un moment historique de
l'histoire du mouvement social alors que
nous sortons
alors que la guerre gronde offrant
alors que l'inflation explose alors que
la crise climatique nous heurte plus
fort que jamais au point de nous obliger
à rationner l'eau source de toute vie
vous n'avez aucun scrupule à conduire le
pays tout entier au blocage mais pour
quel besoin pour quelle urgence est-ce
la nécessité d'un agenda caché de vos
négociations avec la Commission
européenne ou est-ce la seule fierté mal
placée du président de la République qui
considère que le barrage à l'extrême
droite vaut à doublement de sa Royal
personne et qui n'a même pas pris la
peine d'étudier la composition de la
potion qu'il entend faire boire au pays
et à laquelle il n'a visiblement pas
compris grand chose le retrait de ces
textes s'impose cependant pour vous
éviter de perdre la face nous vous
proposons une solution alternative
soumettent donc ce projet dont vous êtes
si fier à l'approbation des Françaises
et des Français ils sont 70% à le
demander 70% à vouloir se prononcer sur
cette réforme 70% à vouloir être maître
de leur propre destin 70% à vouloir
exprimer leur parfaite compréhension de
votre projet de ces prétendus mesures de
justice d'égalité femme homme et de
prise en compte de la pénibilité tout à
sa réélection dont il ne cesse de se
prévaloir abusivement Emmanuel Macron
alors interrogé sur la possibilité
d'avoir recours référendum sur la
réforme des retraites déclarer le 11
avril je n'exclut pas le référendum pour
quelques formes que ce soit je les dis
je suis pour le retrouver notre
discussion ne permet de clarifier les
choses location est ici toute trouvée ce
même Emmanuel Macron qui en appelait au
bon sens des Français à l'occasion de
leur faire réellement confiance
mes chers collègues notre démocratie est
malade il est inconcevable de trouver
dans nos deux chambres une nette
majorité pour approrer j'ai rejeté par
la grande majorité de nos concitoyennes
et de nos concitoyens notre
représentativité est dramatique et notre
légitimité légitimité et menacée il
convient une fois n'est pas coutume de
nous dessaisir de cette réforme de ne
pas voter brutalement dans un déni de
démocratie manifeste cette réforme
bricolée dont personne ne veut nous
avons besoin comme le disait de Gaulle
de savoir ce qu'il en est dans les
esprits et dans les cœurs mes chers
collègues de droite soyez Gaulistes
n'ayez pas peur du peuple votez cette
motion référendaire
merci et donner la parole et le
président du groupe pas écologiste au
Sénat Guillaume guantara donc défendu à
cette motion référendaire on va
maintenant chlore et bien ses prises de
parole des groupes politiques au Sénat
sur cette motion référendaire avec une
prise de parole d'une sénatrice
socialiste Annie Le HOUEROU
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur chers collègues dans un
entretien au Monde l'historien et
sociologue Pierre rozanvallon souligne
que si le président de la République
peut se prévaloir d'une légitimité
procédurale née de son élection il lui
manque la légitimité sociale fondée sur
l'intérêt général et la perception
citoyenne nombreux sont les Français et
les françaises qui ont utilisé le
bulletin de votre Macron pour faire
barrage à l'extrême droite mais pas pour
soutenir sa réforme des retraites le
président de la République ne peut se
prévaloir d'une légitimité pour faire
cette réforme alors même que la France
soulève quel sera à l'arrêt le mardi 7
mars pour dire son opposition cela a été
rappelé notre système de retraite est
l'héritage de combat et de conquêtes
sociales passées rien ne justifie une
telle obstination
renforcer par la droite sénatoriale
notre système actuel est excédentaire en
2022 et son évolution est contrôlée le
rapport du Conseil d'orientation des
retraits de la firme il n'y a ni urgence
ni nécessité le déficit se résorbera
grâce aux réformes entreprises pour
stabiliser la part des retraites dans
notre pays B il n'y a pas de dérapage de
la dépense il y a nécessité d'ajuster
nos recettes nous avons des propositions
réalistes pour un ajustement soutenable
et équitable sans imposer deux ans de
travail obligatoire pour toutes et tous
la mobilisation inédite des Français et
des françaises pour exprimer avec force
et détermination qui ne veulent pas
travailler deux années de plus alors que
les conditions de travail les rendent
incapables de poursuivre leur activité
votre réforme ne fait que des perdants
certains plus que d'autres et les plus
touchés sont les catégories populaires
et les femmes le président de la
République déclarait lui-même pendant la
campagne présidentielle de 2017 je cite
après plus de 20 ans de réforme
successives le problème des retraites
n'est plus un problème financier alors
voilà qu'aujourd'hui l'urgence
financière justifie votre choix de
procédure PLFSS rectificatif
venons-en donc à la forme tous les
Français sont concernés par les
retraites vous affirmez que le président
a été élu en connais de cette réforme
vous vous en mettez de rappeler que le
troisième tour des élections nationales
directes de 2022 ne vous a pas donné une
majorité solide à l'Assemblée nationale
pour l'amener à bien et nous avons ici
au Sénat un texte qui n'a pas été soumis
au vote de l'Assemblée nationale en
restreignant le temps des débats au
Parlement en utilisant l'article 47-1 de
la Constitution vous avez vous-même créé
les conditions de l'obstruction comment
pouvez-vous considérer la réforme des
retraites comme une simple rectification
budgétaire qui n'impacte d'ailleurs que
faiblement l'année 2023 alors que vous
les privez des deux meilleures années de
leur retraite l'usage de cette procédure
d'urgence et le contenu de la loi est
contesté par le Conseil d'État et le
Serein bientôt par le Conseil
constitutionnel face à l'incapacité du
gouvernement de faire voter ce texte
dans les deux chambres soyez à l'écoute
de l'opposition du peuple je vous
appelle à voter cette motion
référendaire en vertu de l'article 11 de
la Constitution pour que le peuple
tranche un référendum sur un sujet aussi
essentiel que celui des retraites
permettrait au gouvernement de vérifier
l'adhésion ou pas du peuple français et
un monsieur Macron de vérifier son
postulat d'accord tacite des Français
sur la réforme les Français et les
françaises veulent prendre leur retraite
de leur vivant nous laisse soutenons
avec force vous l'aurez compris notre
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
soutiendra cette notion référendaire
pour associer le peuple français à cette
réforme de société et je vous invite à
droite à vous associer en votant pour
cette notion à vous remettre au peuple
sale légitime à trancher nos débats dans
le contexte de rejet qui s'exprime dans
la rue avec une unité syndicale inédite
[Applaudissements]
et les différents groupes politiques du
Sénat donc débattu de la motion
référendaire qui est déposée par les
sénateurs de gauche aujourd'hui pour
organiser un référendum sur cette
réforme de retraite et on va maintenant
écouter la réponse la vie du
gouvernement avec Olivier du socle le
ministre du Travail évidemment et sans
surprise le Gouvernement est défavorable
à l'adoption de la motion référendaire
qui a été proposée j'ai entendu
finalement trois arguments ou trois
questions auxquelles je souhaite
apporter les positions du gouvernement
en réponse premier argument concerne la
question de la recevabilité nous avons
évoqué ce sujet hier est-ce que cette
réforme doit être portée dans le cadre
d'un projet de loi de financement la
sécurité sociale rectificative nous
avons eu l'occasion hier madame la
rapporteur général moi-même d'apporter
un son d'éléments de réponse et de
rappeler que le cadre dans lequel nous
sommes les conséquences de cette réforme
sur les comptes sociaux pour l'année
2023 rendent à la fois légitime
recevable et donc justifie le recours à
un projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale il y a malgré tout
c'est une parenthèse que je fais quelque
chose d'assez cocasse pardon pour cette
expression à entendre reprocher au
gouvernement d'avoir organisé une forme
d'obstruction pour deux raisons la
première c'est que le temps de débat
dont dispose le Parlement sur cette
réforme est supérieur autant de débat
dont ta disposer le Parlement sur les
deux réformes précédentes et les choix
faits par le Sénat d'ouvrir un nombre de
jours supplémentaires par rapport à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a illustré ou
conforter celui-ci puis il y a une
deuxième raison c'est que à ma
connaissance ce n'est pas le
gouvernement qui est devant l'Assemblée
nationale a déposé plus de 20 000
amendements dans des séries
identiques je peux vous assurer que
j'avais plus hâte d'entrer dans les
sujets de fonds que d'examiner ces
amendements identiques la deuxième
question à laquelle je vais apporter la
position du gouvernement concerne
finalement la légitimité ou l'intérêt
qu'il y a à maintenir au Parlement cette
capacité à apporter examiner la réforme
des retraites et à travailler sur ces
questions là je crois très fortement à
stratégie légitimité de la démocratie
représentative et du Parlement pour
débattre des retraites j'y crois parce
que l'histoire récente nous a montré que
toutes les réformes de retraite depuis
1980 ont été examinés par le Parlement
il n'y a qu'un légère différence cela a
été évoqué par certains orateurs puisque
en 1980 la réforme a été mise par voie
d'ordonnant mise en œuvre par voie
d'ordonnance après que le Parlement est
habilité le gouvernement à le faire mais
le Parlement c'est toujours saisi de
cette question des retraites et a pu
accompagner mettre en oeuvre des progrès
qui sont des progrès très substantiels
pour l'ensemble des assurés je ne prends
qu'un exemple qui a été évoqué notamment
par le président requier c'est la
question des carrières longues lorsque
l'on se retourne sur un passé récent à
20 ans avant 2003 l'âge de départ à la
retraite était de 60 ans la durée de
cotisation requise était de 37 ans et
demi et dans un système tel que on le
connaissait un assurer une assurée qui
travaille qui faisait des études licence
une maîtrise qui entrait sur le marché
du travail à 22 ans et demi travailler
très exactement 37 ans et demi et
bénéficier d'une retraite à taux plein
de 60 ans et dans le même temps c'est
camarades de classe à l'école pouvait
commencer à travailler très tôt à 14 ans
à 15 ans à 16 ans et elle devait aller
jusqu'à 60 ans et ainsi cotiser 44 45 46
ans pour bénéficier d'une retraite à
taux plein c'est la création du
dispositif de carrière longue dans la
réforme de 2003 qui a apporté une
première réponse et depuis chaque
réforme examinée débattu adopté par le
Parlement a permis de diminuer cet écart
de durée de cotisation à l'échelle d'une
vie pour faire en sorte qu'aujourd'hui
nous arrivions à une situation et ça
sera encore plus vrai si cette réforme
est adoptée où l'écart de durée de
cotisation requise sera finalement
ramené à moins d'un an parfois à
quelques trimestres parce qu'on sait
qu'il n'y a pas de perfection en la
matière et ce seul exemple montre qu'il
y a un intérêt à ce que le Parlement
puisse se saisir ces sujets les creuser
les amender les approfondir et apporter
des dispositions techniques un examen
avoir référendaire ne permettrait pas
enfin la troisième question à laquelle
je veux apporter une réponse c'est
justement quel serait l'intérêt qu'elle
serait l'utilité ou l'opportunité plutôt
de la démarche de confier cette question
ce débat et cette réforme à une question
référendaire je crois et ça a été dit
par plusieurs intervenants que la
complexité du sujet je l'ai évoqué hier
en réponse à la discussion générale
interdit cette démarche interdit cette
démarche parce que aucune réponse
binaire ne peut constituer une réponse à
la question des retraites il a été
évoqué par plusieurs intervenants et
avec des ondes très différents la
question des femmes et en particulier la
question des maires puisque ont été
évoquées les questions relatives au
trimestre accordée et validé à
l'occasion d'une maternité ou au-delà
des trimestres raccordés pour
l'éducation des enfants je suis
convaincu mais ça peut faire l'objet
d'un débat
je suis absolument convaincu que pas un
couple aucun parent aucune femme ne
décide d'avoir un enfant pour espérer
avoir en contrepartie telle ou tel
trimestre ou telle ou telle majoration
c'est un projet de vie c'est un projet
personnel c'est une construction par
contre je suis absolument convaincu que
la maternité tout comme le fait d'élever
des enfants peut-être soit un frein voir
un empêchement à cotisé soit un frein à
la progression à la promotion
professionnelle et donc un facteur
d'inégalité professionnelle notre
système de retraite ne compte rien
aucune disposition qui soit de nature à
marquer créer une inégalité entre les
femmes et les hommes il traduit il
retranscrit dans le calcul des pensions
non pas une volonté d'inégalité mais
l'accumulation d'inégalité tout au long
de la vie et c'est évidemment la
question de l'égalité professionnelle
qui apportera la seule et vraie réponse
soutenable à la question de l'égalité
des pensions entre les femmes et les
hommes par contre même système ne doit
pas s'empêcher de réparer et c'est pour
ça que j'ai dit hier combien nous
regardons avec bienveillance
l'amendement propos par le président
d'otayo est adopté par la commission des
affaires sociales pourquoi parce que
d'une part il permettra il permet de
maintenir un système un système qui
autorise une femme je parle uniquement
des trimestres liés à la maternité les
quatre dans le régime général des deux
dans le secteur public et cela renvoie
au débat sur les droits familiaux que
j'ai évoqué permettra à des femmes ayant
des carrières de pouvoir grâce à ces
trimestres validées compléter leur
carrière éviter la décote c'est ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça
que c'est trimestre ont été pensés dans
un premier temps qu'on met des
contreparties et des trimestres qui ne
pouvaient être cotisées au moment de la
grossesse et de l'accouchement et dans
un deuxième temps comme un une réponse
peut-être au carré râché mais nous avons
une situation qui fait qu'avec
l'augmentation pas celle-ci mais
l'augmentation depuis
1993 depuis 2003 pardonnez-moi de l'âge
de départ à la retraite nous avons une
situation c'est trimestre dit de
maternité peuvent dans certains cas dans
le cas où les femmes ont une carrière
complète ou quasiment complète perdre
d'une certaine manière leur utilité dès
lors où que la carrière peut être
complète sans avoir recours aux besoins
de cette trimestre et dans ce cas il
faut se demander quelle est l'utilité de
ces trimestre et l'utilité de cette
trimestre peut-être non pas de compenser
une incapacité à cotiser pendant un
temps mais à compenser des inégalités de
carrière que peuvent encore provoquer
suicité et malheureusement le fait
d'avoir des enfants et de consacrer du
temps à leur éducation et donc
l'alternative qui est ainsi proposée à
la fois maintenir ce bénéfice de temps
pour les femmes qui en ont besoin du
fait d'une carrière hachée mais
permettre à celles qui ont une carrière
complète ou quasiment complète quelques
trimestres avant l'âge d'ouverture des
droits de bénéficier d'une surcote parce
que finalement
la démonstration est peut-être un peu
simpliste si elles ont réussi à avoir
une carrière complète cela signifie que
leur grossesse leur maternité ne les a
pas empêché de mener une carrière mais
peut les avoir empêché de progresser
aussi rapidement que leurs collègues
hommes et donc permettre à ces femmes
qui ont une carrière complète ou
quasiment complète alors de bénéficier
non pas de temps validé mais d'une
surcote en termes de pension nous paraît
permettre une alternative intéressante
et posant une première pierre une
première brique pour le chantier des
droits familiaux que nous aurons à
aborder et élaborer d'ici le pellet FSS
2024 j'ai pris cet exemple qui renvoie
là encore à la complexité que j'ai
évoqué hier pour dire tout simplement et
j'entamine par là qu'une question
binaire à laquelle on apporte une
réponse par oui ou par non est une
question trop simple trop directe et
donc une opportune pour aborder une
réforme comme celle-ci je compte plus
sur la richesse des débats du Parlement
pour permettre d'améliorer le texte
ici monsieur le ministre et le
gouvernement qui est donc défavorable à
cette motion de référendum déposée par
les sénateurs de gauche on va maintenant
normalement passer au scrutin public sur
cette notion référendaire on écoute le
président du Sénat monsieur le
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
les explications de vote et donc le
sénateur écologiste Daniel broyet prend
la parole on l'écoute
mais bien sûr aussi nous vivons une
crise démocratique d'une grande
profondeur dans l'écart entre le peuple
et le gouvernement ne cesse de
s'accroître étant l'écart entre
l'immense majorité de nos concitoyens et
la majorité de notre chambre est grand
des millions de personnes manifestent le
sentiment d'injustice sociale et d'une
profondeur rarement atteint
l'unanimité syndicale s'exprime face à
cette réforme et chers collègues si nous
ne bougeons rien le populisme sans
nourrira alors comment sortir de cette
crise démocratique nos collègues du
groupe centriste appellent à l'ouverture
d'un grand débat social c'est une
position que je trouve pour ma part très
intéressante et très intelligente quand
on ne peut pas parler des retraites sans
parler du travail lui-même ce que ce
texte ne permet pas parce qu'il est
inscrit dans un texte
significatif de finance mais cette
proposition de nos collègues sont
tristes supposent une seule chose
c'est que le débat commence par ce round
social et pas par le vote d'une loi ici
nous faisons tout à l'envers sous
l'impulsion de ce gouvernement nous
changeons le mix énergétique avant le
débat sur les choix énergétiques et nous
votons une réforme de la retraite avant
le débat sur les sujets du travail c'est
un problème démocratique qui nourrira
des populistes
[Applaudissements]
des citoyens appellent à une convention
à une convention citoyenne sur ce sujet
des retraites moi j'avoue que cette idée
me séduit parce que je m'étonne jeune
sénateur qu'en aucun cas nous ne
parvenons ici à trouver des consensus et
que lorsqu'on réunit des conventions
citoyennes sur des sujets aussi délicats
que la fin de vie ou le climat il soit
capable d'élaborer ses consensus il y a
là un problème qui doit nous faire
réfléchir nous parlementaires sur cette
façon dont le débat est finalement
bloqué à l'intérieur de nos institutions
alors il reste la dernière proposition
celle du référendum elle a de grandes
inconvénients notamment par son côté
binaire mais il n'y a jamais de honte à
redonner au peuple la capacité de
décider
et ensuite madame ponce
mes chers collègues après chaque
élection on découvre un taux
d'abstention abyssal on fait des grandes
déclarations sur la crise démocratique
et puis à peine le temps passant on
finit par oublier la gravité du
décrochage d'une large partie de notre
population notamment dans le monde
salarié avec les choix politiques du
pays
et là et pourquoi parce que depuis des
années des années sont votés des
réformes qui comme un rouleau
compresseur attaque notre modèle social
et notre modèle républicain et on peut
jamais rien on vote on fait l'alternance
ça change pas beaucoup on vote pour un
président qui nous dit mon programme
tout mon programme alors qu'il s'est
fait lire contre Marine Le Pen les gens
n'y croient plus à cette démocratie il a
donc fondamental de retrouver un nouvel
équilibre entre le choix et fernander
qui donne au peuple la parole ou en
général il vote et de l'autre côté la
démocratie représentative si on n'avance
pas sur les deux jambes les deux vont
être affaiblis
de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit pas de sous
des tailles on peut toujours faire des
amendements à pelletfss pour améliorer
la condition de la retraite des femmes
et ceci ou cela c'est l'essentiel
la référendum de voir lieu sur
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire le recul de
l'âge de la retraite légale à 64 ans
comme massivement notre pays refuse
et ne pas vouloir faire ça c'est creuser
la tombe de notre vision républicaine
c'est creuser la tombe de notre
démocratie alors mes amis de MLR mes
amis mes collègues mais néanmoins amis
de LR
je vous rappelle non seulement le
général de Gaulle mais commencez pas à
nous raconter que le référendum n'est
pas une bonne chose parce que pour pour
faire un homme sur l'immigration alors
ça madame Pécresse tombe tambour et
trompette mais quand il s'agit de
s'opposer
madame la Présidente
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président alors le
constat est sans appel l'Ifop 75% des
ouvriers ont foyers 63% des cas sont
opposés à la réforme
59% sont favorables à une augmentation
des cotisations élab 77 % des actifs
jugent la réforme injuste 66%
inefficaces 61% pas nécessaire 72% des
actifs soutiennent la mobilisation et
60% souhaitent qu'elles se durcisse avec
des blocages aussi 59% trouve que le
responsable du conflit social et des
blocages et le gouvernement toutes ces
enquêtes ne font que mettre au grand
jour l'opposition massive et sans
équivoque de la population et des actifs
qui trouvent eux aussi que leur retrait
et non négociable la démocratie c'est le
régime du peuple pour le peuple par le
peuple et pourtant vous nier la
légitimité sociale de la population et
des syndicats majoritairement opposés au
projet revanon complète Rousseau chers
collègues millions et ce pour la seule
légitimité électorale d'avoir été élu
alors que chacun sait que vous le devez
d'abord au circonstances du second que
ce n'était pas un blanc saint à votre
programme et certainement pas à se
prolongement de l'âge de la retraite
vous faites semblant aujourd'hui de
l'oublier vous le disiez entre les deux
tours pour demander nos voix la
population doit avoir le droit de
débattre et cette réforme de cette
réforme et retrouver la parole alors que
vous tronquez aujourd'hui le débat
parlementaire si le peuple vote contre
la réforme du gouvernement il ne vous
restera que le retrait ou de dissoudre
le peuple comme disait bertolbrest les
écologistes donc pour toutes ces raisons
soutiennent cette notion référendaire
un président
qui monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues je voudrais simplement vous
rappeler que le référendum le référendum
est un outil un outil démocratique qui
permet de trancher dans un moment de
doute un certain nombre de questions et
il me semble que nous sommes au cœur de
ce doute et je pense donc que le
référendum est nécessaire alors bien
évidemment il y a des réticences du
président de la République il y a des
réticences du gouvernement pour
convoquer un référendum mais je dois
dire que ça ne m'étonne guère car ce
qu'il craignent et un peu ce que
craignent aussi nos collègues de la
majorité sénatoriale ce qu'il craigne
c'est une remise en cause de leur
légitimité or ce n'est pas le sujet ce
n'est pas du tout le sujet et si
Monsieur Macron se félicite et cela a
été dit du bon sens des Français il doit
aller donc au bout de sa logique et
favoriser l'expression de ce bon sens et
non la crainte je pense que rejeter
cette s'est envoyé un message très
mauvais au 90% d'actifs et aux soins
plus de 60% de Français qui veulent le
retrait de ce texte parmi lesquels je
voudrais insister parmi lesquels des
électrices et des électeurs de Macron au
premier tour de la présidentielle mais
aussi des électrices et des électeurs
qui soutiennent et ont voté pour les
candidats des candidates de la droite
qu'elles soient LR ou sans triste aux
dernières élections on peut s'interroger
sur leur niveau de tolérance de ces
électricités sélecteurs car cette
réforme vient compléter des contraintes
financières et sociales qui leur sont
imposés depuis plusieurs années
maintenant donc la colère est là le
ressentiment est là il serait temps que
vous sortiez de votre bulle pour
entendre non seulement les flatteurs
mais surtout en temps de celles et ceux
qui
exigent pardon le retrait de ce texte
pour notre part et nous en sommes
signataires nous soutenons cette notion
référendaire
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président
quand on en arrive dans nos débats à
invoquer le général de Gaulle c'est en
général qui a un grand trouble au fond
dans l'assemblée et il y a un grand
trouble et un désordre institutionnel et
il ne date pas des débats à l'Assemblée
nationale et de comportements les
comportements auxquels on a assisté il
vient de bien plus loin ce désordre
institutionnel c'est le chef de l'État
qui en est responsable car dès son
premier mandat il a marqué son mépris
des organisations intermédiaires il a
quasiment théorisé même et se mépris des
organisations intermédiaires il s'est
déroulé et aujourd'hui il explose à la
figure du Parlement pour contourner les
organisations parce qu'on peut on peut
mener une réforme de retraite en
négociant et en ayant au moins la
sentiment d'une partie des organisations
syndicales ça n'est pas si ancien dans
notre histoire je vous le rappelle mais
c'est pas le pari qui a été pris par le
chef de l'État c'est de les contourner
résultat un front syndical total
remarquer ce gouvernement nous y
habitues avec les professions de santé
c'est la même chose il arrive à tous les
liguer contre eux et à échouer à signer
un accord conventionnel je ferme la
parenthèse mais ça n'est pas une
parenthèse c'est sa ligne de conduite et
donc il arrive au Parlement et face à un
peuple qui dit non face à des
organisations syndicales qui disent non
il imagine une procédure
institutionnelle qui est bancale sur le
plan constitutionnel et qui met le Sénat
dans la situation d'être l'Assemblée du
peuple ce que nous ne sommes pas ce que
nous ne sommes pas nous sommes la
chambre des territoires et bien c'est un
désordre institutionnel total qui a créé
le chef de l'État c'est un chaos qui ne
peut pas se résoudre de façon apaisée
par la voix parlementaire et croyez bien
que je le regrette il n'y a qu'une
solution c'est de retirer ce projet et
oui c'est d'aller vers le peuple
pour expliquer son vote non si si vous
aviez demandé
si vous le demandez plus
[Musique]
mais moi j'ai entendu dans les arguments
s'opposant à cette motion référendaire
des plaidoyer pour la démocratie
parlementaire
je prends date parce que oui le
Parlement oui l'assemblée où il le Sénat
c'est le
c'est le fondement du fonctionnement
démocratique dans notre République et
donc très souvent on a dû le défendre
quand il a été brutalisé par différents
gouvernements et en particulier depuis
Emmanuel Macron cette brutalisation est
constante depuis
quelques années les procédures d'urgence
qui devaient être exceptionnel sont la
règle sont la coutume donc mes chers
collègues qui venaient faire ses
plaidoyer et monsieur le ministre en
particulier
pourquoi à chaque fois à ce point le
brutalisé mais on est dans une situation
très particulière
on va toucher à la vie de millions de
nos concitoyens alors que le Président
de la République
dans son élection
n'a pas été investi par le peuple de
faire cette réforme et d'ailleurs s'il
avait été ça se serait vu au
législatives il aurait eu une majorité
et donc on est devant une réforme
majeure qui touche à la vie de millions
de nos concitoyens
et le message et le mandat parlementaire
n'est pas clair
celui du président celui de la première
ministre celui des majorités et en plus
de cela une mobilisation syndicale qui
est massive et des enquêtes d'opinion
qui touchent
disent qu'une grande majorité de
Français contre et donc la seule façon
de dénouer cette crise cette crise
démocratique sur cette question et que
le peuple prenne la parole par voie
référendum et ça veut dire un débat dans
le pays bien entendu
d'autres demandes d'explication de vote
je n'envoie pas la discussion donc nous
allons passer
au moment du vote sur l'article unique
de la motion de renvoi référendum je
rappelle quand l'application d'article
59 du règlement le scrutin public et de
droit
donc
c'est l'article 56 du règlement qui est
appliqué maintenant le scrutin est
ouvert
et les sénateurs qui vont donc voter sur
cette motion référendaire déposée par
les trois groupes politiques de gauche
ici à la Haute Assemblée à l'idée de
cette motion c'est de proposer
l'organisation d'un référendum sur cette
réforme des retraites et si jamais elle
est votée et bien elle ira à l'Assemblée
nationale qui devra également la voter
et ensuite elle pourra donc être soumise
au président de la République pour
éventuellement organiser un référendum
sur cette réforme des retraites donc là
on est dans un scrutin public ordinaire
au Sénat ça voudrait ça veut dire que
vous pourrez et bien connaître le vote
de chaque sénateur sur cette motion
référendaire notamment en allant sur le
site du Sénat c'est le principe de ce
scrutin public les sénateurs qui votent
sur leur tablette électronique sur cette
notion référendaire qui a été déposée
par la gauche le vote est clos
le scrutin
je réouvre le scrutin
on finalise ce scrutin public ordinaire
des sénateurs sur cette motion
référendaire tous les sénateurs n'ont
pas encore voté sur leur tablette
électronique je vous rappelle qu'elle a
quand même peu de chance de passer
puisqu'elle est déposée par la gauche du
Sénat qui est minoritaire à la Haute
Assemblée face à la majorité des
sénateurs de droite et du centre qui ont
exprimé leur volonté ce matin de pouvoir
avoir un débat au Parlement sur cette
réforme des retraites alors que
l'huissier de l'hémicycle fait signe
normalement au président du Sénat que le
scrutin est clos et on va bientôt
écouter les résultats
si administrateur du Sénat analyse les
résultats
du scrutin
votant 344 exprimé 344 pour 93 contre
251 le Sénat n'a pas adopté
en conséquence mes chers collègues nous
allons poursuivre la discussion du
projet de loi de financement
projet de loi
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale je
vais maintenant suspendre ce sera
reprise à 17h pour l'examen des articles
mais si on s'est suspendus souhaite bon
courage à la commission la séance est
suspendue voilà
voilà le Sénat donc rejeté la motion
référendaire déposée par les sénateurs
de gauche pour organiser un référendum
sur la réforme des retraites il y aura
donc bien un débat au Sénat à cet
après-midi à partir de 17h sur cette
réforme des retraites Steve on va vous
retrouver dans la tribune de l'hémicycle
du Sénat quels ont été les temps forts
rapidement de cette séance ce matin oui
Alex c'était un peu de salle 2 ambiances
ici derrière moi à droite on a vu un
hémistique très clairsemé j'ai compté
seulement une vingtaine de sénateurs LR
sur un groupe qui en compte 145
normalement à gauche on était très
remontés évidemment puisque la motion
référendum référendaire émaner
évidemment des rangs de la gauche à
gauche justement on a mis en avant la
volonté de laisser les Français
s'exprimer directement sur cette réforme
des retraites de laisser vivre en
quelque sorte la démocratie et puis à la
droite on a critiqué cette proposition
de référendum à référendum trop binaire
pour un sujet trop complexe on ici les
sénateurs de droite vous l'avez entendu
donc la motion référendaire a été
rejetée par le Sénat ça surtout permis
cette séquence a surtout permis à la
gauche de serrer les rangs et de monter
de montrer un front uni face à cette
réforme des retraites qu'elle rejette en
bloc merci beaucoup Steve effectivement
c'est l'information de la matinée la
majorité de droite et du centre du Sénat
à rejeter à cette motion effet Inder sur
la réforme des retraites et on vous
donne donc rendez-vous cet après-midi à
17h en direct sur public Senna puisque
le Sénat va commencer à l'examen des
articles de cette réforme des retraites
avec 4200 amendements qui vont être
discutés pendant 10 jours par les
sénateurs un débat qui s'annonce très
tendu dès ce soir avec la question de la
suppression des régimes spéciaux vous
pourrez suivre tout ça sur Public Sénat
sur notre antenne et